questionable vitamins awards show
mishaps and new Kim Kardashian photos
that have nothing to do with the show
but I wanted to show you because they
scare me American Horror Story delicate
has just released episode 2 and along
with it a new swath of Clues Mysteries
and theories to dive into so in this
video we'll be taking a deep dive into
the biggest questions the series has to
offer and I've left timestamps below so
you can see all the topics I'll be
covering but before we begin make sure
to like And subscribe so I can send Emma
Roberts a new skincare routine the end
of episode 1 saw Anna's Home invaded by
a hooded figure but as Anna's husband
and detectives would have us believe
this was all in Anna's head no one was
seen on the security cameras coming into
or out of the building although the
windows were open in her apartment this
Intruder just so happened to arrive in
the brief time Dex went out to get dog
food but the most damning evidence that
suggests this was all in her head is the
lipstick all over her hands it was
lipstick that was used to write don't do
it Anna on her mirror lipstick she tells
Siobhan won't come off this lipstick was
given to her by dex's longtime friend
Talia who I can't help but think
secretly hates Anna and would rather
have the Dex be with his ex the now dead
Adeline when Siobhan comes over to
comfort Anna the two sing in the mirror
and it cracks is there something
Supernatural going on here or is there
singing just that bad tell you little
girls ain't laughing at me for your
information I wasn't a as far as we know
no one but Anna has seen the mysterious
woman known as ivy with the current
information my best guess is that the
Intruder is her it's also possible that
Ivy isn't real rather a character made
up by Anna's inner psyche to stop her
from having this child it would explain
the don't do it Anna lipstick and nurse
Ivy causing this miscarriage according
to her name tag avi's last name is Aaron
Reich which in German means rich in
honor I have a hard time believing this
character is evil for the sake of being
evil and that there must be some sort of
motivation here for example could Anna's
baby grow up to be the next Michael
Langdon or perhaps a new breed of
superhumans we saw on Miss preacher's
Reddit page the last episode I theorized
that Dex may have some ulterior motives
in getting his wife pregnant he seems to
have a special rapport with Dr Hill and
I even argued that the baby inside Anna
may not even be her own and that Dex is
merely using her as a surrogate it when
Anna calls the doctor's office this
episode you can hear Dr Hill in the
background trying to tell his assistant
that he isn't available so something is
definitely going on here now there's one
quick line here I thought was really
interesting that points at dex's
resentment towards her when the
detectives mistakenly call him by his
wife's last name he says that's okay
happens all the time price I pay for
being married is such an amazing woman I
just felt like there was so much
resentment packed into the delivery of
this line I got my eyes on you Dex later
in the episode Talia makes it a point to
talk about how she'd be resentful if she
were the quote-unquote trophy wife in a
relationship who didn't make all the
money as far as we know Dex is the
trophy husband with Anna being the more
successful of the two the writers here
are bombarding us with Mr X and red
herrings when it comes to what's causing
Anna's mental decline we have her own
these progesterone suppositories
vitamins and a new cocktail given to her
by Siobhan I'm no doctor but I've never
seen vitamin B12 come in these creepy
vials Anna also seems to forget little
things like calling Dr Hill's Clinic the
other day she accidentally cuts her
husband in the face and days pass by
like nothing Anna has this calendar
mocking the amount of days until she can
take her pregnancy test but moments
later the two weeks have already passed
is this because of her deteriorating
mental state or could something more
Sinister be happening during these
blackouts I could totally see how the
drugs she's on have her pass out so that
Dr Hill can perform more tests as she
wakes up having no recollection of these
events Anna also has hallucinations such
as Dex kissing Adeline or the woman in
the black dress notice how the bathroom
goes from having multiple women in it to
just this one woman in a matter of
seconds and she's like yes when Anna's
skin peels off also I gotta say it was
absolutely hilarious how they shot This
Woman's head hitting the counter I don't
know if it was supposed to be funny but
I was just like what the hell also bonus
points if you caught HS Aluma Zachary
Quinto presenting the awards there's
something I gotta mention and it's
Anna's vomit there are three separate
occasions this episode where she up
Chucks and I can't really show all of
them or I'll get demonetized and the
color that comes out in all these
different occasions is wildly different
pink a bright yellow and a completely
black and this could just be a
production air but there's no black
vomit on her when she awakens at the
award show Anna is also given a sedative
without her consent which I was not too
fond of and wakes up and Siobhan is just
laying in bed with her it's all just
super weird early on in the episode Anna
develops a zit on her face which
progressively gets worse 12 weeks have
passed when she gets her ultrasound from
Ivy that's 12 weeks she's had this
gnarly thing and she never gets it
looked at to make matters worse we have
this shot of her skin literally peeling
off when this happened I immediately
thought of a snake shedding its skin and
guess who calls Anna a snake but none
other than Miss preacher on her
annihilate Anna account snake imagery
can also be seen in the opening credits
like Ivy we only get a little bit of new
information about Miss preacher this
episode in fact she's barely in it only
visible in one of Anna's hallucinations
where we see her face covered in blood a
knot to the dream Anna had where she
ripped out her tongue according to Dr
Hill's office Miss preacher is a kook
who drops off ivf's murder pamphlets
once a week after taking a selfie with
her PR team Anna finds the annihilate
Anna account which we saw last episode
has commented a few posts down is a
different user named preacher speaks
which I think is just another account
run by Miss preacher this user posts
tons of articles about conspiracy
theories including one about Queen Mary
the first of England striking a deal
with the devil to secure her place on
the throne makes me wonder if Dex or
Anna made some sort of deal with the
devil to have this baby born we also
have this article about a new breed of
superhumans could Anna be unknowingly
carrying one of them secret Celtic
rituals and a cabal of witches are also
mentioned is it just me or did anyone
else find it weird that Sonia shock
cross just happened to call the exact
moment Anna and Dex found out they were
pregnant I've theorized that Sonia is
either a Adeline or B a twin sister who
is secretly with Dex if Anna is somehow
carrying a surrogate child of Adelines
or Sonia's you better believe Sonia
would be calling non-stop to find out if
Anna was pregnant now listen to this
other clue Dex tells Anna that he and
Sonia are still chatting because they're
opening up a pop-up shop in the Hamptons
and guess where Dex takes Anna a few
days later the Hamptons coincidence I
also found it super strange that a
picture of Adeline dextalia and Theo
just so happens to be in the kitchen
drawer where it could easily be found
plus this whole security thing with
Kamal screams surveillance Kamal isn't
here to protect Anna but to keep eyes on
her Annie even remarks that it's weird
they're in a glass house where people
could easily keep tabs on them we also
learned that Talia is super rich having
sold the startup at 29 and is a venture
capitalist I can't help think she has
some sort of vested interest in Anna and
dex's baby and perhaps this is something
to do with something she's funding like
super breed of humans for example just
wanted to throw that out there at night
Anna hears the sounds of women
whispering and chanting could some sort
of ritual be going on underneath the
house while Anna sleeps this could
explain why Talia wanted them to come at
the end of the episode Anna deals with
the tragic news that she had a
miscarriage her child was going to be a
boy but the biggest shock is the
hospital has no records of a nurse named
Ivy this still raises the question was
Ivy in her head and Anna did this
herself or is Ivy a real person I want
to hear your thoughts and theories in
the comments below that's it for this
episode thanks for watching please be
sure to like And subscribe and for more
bad takes you can follow me on Twitter
and Instagram at Big story YT until next
time remember
situation girl that means you're hot